le ministre de l'agriculture jean
glavany tient bon face aux demandes
européennes de laisser entrer le buzz
britannique sur territoire français
pas question de lever l'embargo mais la
france est plus en plus isolé même si le
refus du gouvernement s'appuie sur
l'avis négatif de l' agence française de
sécurité sanitaire des aliments
c'est le principe de précaution qui fait
ainsi face aux appels au boycott de
produits français lançait outre manche
et aux menaces de sanctions financières
prévues par bruxelles commentaires
thierry y ait refusé la france maintient
toujours son embargo contre le boeuf
britannique se réfugiant derrière l'avis
d'un comité de scientifiques français
indépendant et le ministre de
l'agriculture a confirmé ce choix cet
après midi à l'assemblée nationale
pouvait-il faire autrement je vous
prends tes - corée corps et on dit si le
gouvernement avait fait film sur la vie
de cette agence et avait décidé
d'appliquer la levée de l'embargo serait
décidé par l'union européenne
de l'autre côté de la danse les éleveurs
britannique manifeste et guettent les
camions français appelant au boycott
moins violent le ministre de
l'agriculture a tout de même précisé
qu'à titre personnel il ne consommerait
plus de produits français
je ne suis pas pour une campagne de
boycott mais je suis très en colère ce
n'est pas encore une tragédie
shakespearienne mais c'est déjà une
crise européenne bruxelles somme paris
de justifier sa décision avant le 8
octobre et david byrne s'appuyant lui
sur le comité directeur scientifique
européen et plutôt ferme à l'égard des
français
les scientifiques français n'ont rien
apporté de nouveau et nous devons donc
nous acheminer rapidement vers une
solution politique et diplomatie oblige
bruxelles se dit prêt à réexaminer des
analyses scientifiques françaises mais
jusqu'où cela peut-il aller acte 1 une
mise en demeure
exemple pour un avis motivé acte iii
c'est plus grave
une saisine de la cour de justice
européenne acte iv une deuxième saisine
et risque d'une astreinte financière
mais d'ici là un océan aura coulé sous
le pont européen la cour de justice
jusqu'à aujourd'hui n'a jamais condamné
la france à payer un franc on a des
procédures en cours mais il n'y a pas eu
encore d'arrêt
contrairement aux poètes bruxelles
n'oublie pas mais il prend son temps
pour nous français c'est plutôt
rassurant